in the far north of norway it is forever
winter this is exercise cold response
several weeks of military games
involving 30 000 troops from 27
countries most of them nato alliance
members
these troops are from finland a country
with a long shared border with russia
finland's not a nato country and it's
historically neutral but since the
invasion of ukraine an increasing number
of finns and neighboring swedes want
their nations to join the nato alliance
it's worrying the soldiers the civilians
and it's not nice
it's something we speak about often
and everyone in here just wants peace
not a war
but these soldiers are reluctant to
discuss what abandoning neutrality might
actually mean i think that that is a
political question and maybe
i i won't answer to that one
while a real war rages in eastern europe
these troops from finland and other
countries are being put through their
paces in the harshest of possible
climates in the hope that these skills
will never have to be used for real
theater we're showing around a
state-of-the-art field hospital that can
be erected in a matter of hours
precisely the kind of equipment
ukrainian forces desperately need but
can't get their hands on
and elsewhere this norwegian made
anti-aircraft weapon the only one in the
world
nato countries have spent billions of
dollars arming ukraine but supplies have
to be carefully calibrated
do too much and risk being drawn into a
direct conflict with russia
the invasion of ukraine poses the
biggest threat to european security in a
generation
several nato states are now rushing to
ramp up their defence spending and the
uk and norway announced a new agreement
on defending the increasingly strategic
arctic as the west weans itself off
russian energy supplies it's looking to
norway to make up for shortfalls of oil
and gas the arctic sea also has rich
fishing grounds and future trade routes
we have to be in a position to uphold
our our rules and our international laws
such as freedom navigation should the
ice melt even further and the countries
like china will seek to use maybe these
routes
to sail through and russia might seek
these routes to control these are long
planned exercises but no matter how you
frame this they're a massive show of
force aimed squarely at moscow 220
aircraft 50 warships tens of thousands
of troops putin's actions in ukraine
have rejuvenated old alliances and
expanded nato's reach and appeal
precisely the opposite of what the
kremlin wants leave barker al-jazeera in
northern norway